I live and die by Miley Cyrus I like
Taylor Swift better than Led Zeppelin
I've put a Coldplay song on every mix
I've ever made
bless me Father for I have sinned these
are my confessions
I know citizen Kane's the greatest movie
of all time I have no idea why there's
just something about Solange that speaks
to me more than Beyonce I don't get why
people like Batman so much I've had a
subscription to The New Yorker for nine
years and I just put it on my coffee
table for two months and then throw it
out I've never read an article my home
page is TMZ on my phone and my desktop I
fell asleep halfway through watching a
Clockwork Orange but I still have that
poster in my bedroom I've seen the video
for shake it off more times than I've
called my parents the first feminist I
connected with was Shania Twain I hated
The Dark Knight Rises I told people Bane
was cool but that voice was stupid in
the movie was terrible
whenever I throw a coin into a fountain
I hope that Brad and Jen get back
together I like Star Wars Episode one I
thought Jar Jar Binks was funny Ke$ha is
my spirit animal I know all the words
the love story I don't know my
girlfriend's birthday
I thought ariana grande was a Starbucks
drink I love the song Mambo number five
and I really wish my name was in that
song I can only come if I'm watching a
Steve Harvey Show